who reviewed the deck and said i have a
great idea
while we're being investigated for
uh young women having body issues and
getting anorexia and bulimia and
depression and anxiety from instagram i
have a great idea to caress in our new
product
let's get young men
to be influenced by living in a virtual
world version of grand theft auto where
you murder and beat people and run them
over with stolen cars
are you people insane the answer is
they're not insane they are capitalists
and they are
just absolutely interested in the stock
price going up and to the right they do
not care about society they are liars
they care about making money and let's
face it grand theft auto where you get
to be in an immersive world and beat
people up and murder them and drive over
them is going to be the dystopian insane
running man future that will print money
that's why they're doing it and somebody
over there in comms needs to be fired
for not
sitting sucked down and saying
are you [ __ ] crazy
you literally want to tell people when
we're launching this new vision that
grand theft auto is a key piece of it
and you think this is the best idea
would tim cook do this
would jeff bezos do this would steve
jobs do this no
they would literally say
we're trying to
make people think this is good for
society
grand theft auto is
a parent's nightmare
why on earth would we feature that
and you notice they didn't show any
highlights from gta because it would
have been somebody like literally
beating up a postman or running over you
know uh a baby carriage
oh my lord it's
i mean you can't make this stuff up
suck also talks about open standards in
the metaverse
which is even more funny to me because
he has been on a jihad for decades
to reverse all open standards and to
steal and close off and destroy open
source and open standards
by forcing people to use his login and
by not supporting open standards here's
51 seconds of an absolutely delusional
and unself-aware
clueless zuckerberg explaining open
standards to us the industry that was
built on open standards who absolutely
hates and despises what zuckerberg has
done to open standards play the 51
seconds
teleporting around the metaverse is
going to be like clicking a link on the
internet it's an open standard in order
to unlock the potential of the metaverse
there needs to be interoperability and
that goes beyond just taking your avatar
and digital items across different apps
and experiences which we are already
building an api to support you want to
know that when you buy something or
create something that your items will be
useful in a lot of contexts and you're
not going to be locked into one world or
platform you want to know that you own
your items not a platform the metaverse
isn't something we're building so much
as it's something we're building for
across the industry we need to bring
that same imagination and commitment to
building for interoperability openness
safety and privacy as we do for all the
other product aspects of the metaverse
these have to be fundamental building
blocks oh my god
it's so ridiculous this is like the guy
like who just robbed your house telling
you you don't need to lock your door
are you people crazy
you literally stole everybody's data
you then let cambridge analytic and
everybody else on the inside use that
data
you pulled the rug out from under people
who bought pages and spent money
building their follower account and then
you deprecated their follower account
you made people use your own
cryptocurrencies you deprecate you know
your own ecoins back in the day mana in
games and then you had an app developer
program which you shut off and screwed
all these app developers do you think we
don't remember what you did to app
developers for the first five years with
the facebook platform can somebody
please pull up the videos of zuckerberg
saying this exact thing and then pull up
the headlines after that point and do a
super cut of all the developers he
destroyed zenga and everybody else who
he put the screws to and screwed if you
partner with zuckerberg you will get
screwed do not believe him and if he was
absolutely um committed to this why
isn't he doing it in instagram and
facebook and what's that right now
why are those not open source why is
your data not portable why are the login
systems not standard he's a liar
basically he's a liar and he is now
trying to convince us that this time it
will be different when somebody shows
you who they are
believe them
that it's that simple he has screwed
over every partner he has worked with
and even the people he bought companies
from and he made billionaires hate him
instagram founders whatsapp founders the
list goes on and on they all despise
zuckerberg
can you imagine making people
billionaires and making them tens of
billions of dollars and they still hate
you there's a reason people don't trust
zuckerberg it's because he has not
earned trust
and then he's here telling us that this
time it's going to be different and this
time the metaverse is going to be open
sorry you can say you had some big giant
come to jesus moment about open
standards
and now he's trying to flip the script
and kind of say apple is the closed
system this is all like a high level
leveling game of poker that zuckerberg
is just not good at we all see what
you're doing zuckerberg you're trying to
put these digs into apple for charging a
whole bunch because they blocked you
from tracking users and you can't make
as much money with app installs we see
it from a mile away
if the metaverse is going to be the next
platform
it's essential that facebook not control
it
if you're a developer you should not
support this if you're a user you should
not support this if you're an
entrepreneur you should not work for his
platform davis should only support open
standards in this regard and i think
this is the area where cryptocurrency
distributed systems and dows and other
non-controlled open source communities
with financial incentives built into
them can really shine if this is in fact
the future which is a big question
we can't let zak win we need to hashtag
boycott
meta at all costs
and if you're a developer why would you
work to make zuckerberg richer when you
can work on the open source projects own
the cryptocurrencies own the real estate
own the nfts if you do believe this is
going to happen and that's not
guaranteed why would you go work and be
a peasant to zuckerberg's 50 billion
dollars when you could go make 10
million dollars being an open source
developer and just picking which
currencies and real estate you want to
buy in the metaverse it's a terrible
decision for any developer to go to work
for zuckerberg as opposed to an open
metaverse project